catching cancer at its earliest stages
when its most treatable can save
countless lives but the million dooll
question is in an otherwise healthy body
made up of trillions of cells how can we
zero in on a small group of Rogue cancer
cells the answer I think may be rooted
in something that thanks in a pandemic
we have all come to know quite well and
that is RNA I think these days everyone
has a basic understanding of how RNA
works again thanks to the covid vaccines
but basically RNA is transcribed from
DNA in the cell and messenger RNA
specifically serves as a template for
protein synthesis so usually the more
mRNA you have in the cell the more
protein you get but our Discovery is a
little bit
different we have found a new class of
rnas that have changed how we think
about cancer detection these are
relatively small rnas and they don't
actually code for any protein so they're
non-coding and since we found them we
got to name them and we have called them
orphan noncoding rnas or encar for
short these on caras have not only
changed and transformed their approach
to cancer detection from blood
noninvasively but I've also theyve also
helped open a window into the tumor
itself for us so leveraging these rnas
we are not only detecting cancer earlier
we are actually peering in suit biology
so with that short introduction let me
break down the science for you as you
may know every cell in our body shares
the same genetic code as every other
cell it's as if our cells have access to
the same Pantry but then they use
different recipes to mix the same
ingredients into different dishes it's
actually the diversity in genomic
recipes that gives us the more than 200
cell types we have in our bodies each
with their own distinct role and
function like skin cells for example or
neurons and as you can imagine there is
a complex Machinery in place in the cell
that governs this process and tells the
cell for each of its 20,000 genes how
much of them it needs to express to be a
healthy well functioning cell now cancer
cells being the resourceful survivalist
that they are they actually hijack
components of this Machinery to their
advantage and they do this to increase
the expression of genes that would help
the tumor grow and spread throughout the
body or silence or downregulate genes
whose job is to keep cancer in
check another way of putting this is
that cancer cells are basically hacking
that original genomic recipe that I told
you
about now a few years ago we made an
interesting discovery that it's actually
a consequence of this genomic
reprogramming that happens in cancer
cells is actually a Hallmark of cancer
basically parts of the genome that is
normally silent and inactive in healthy
cells becomes activated in
Cancer and a direct consequence of this
activation is the birth of a new kind of
RNA that we only see these rnas in
cancer but not really in healthy cells
now over the past few years we have
spent a lot of time basically mapping uh
these cancer emergent rnas across human
cancers and as I told you earlier you
have come to name them onc
carnas now what is even more interesting
is that which ancares I see in a given
sample is not random it's actually tied
back to the type or subtype of cancer
that I'm looking at so collect itively
ancarat actually provide a digital
molecular barcode that captures cancer
cell identity and it's actually unique
to the type or subtype of
cancer but how are these molecular
barcod actually
useful so it turns out ancarat are are
not actually confined to cancer cells
some of them are nicely packaged and
released into the blood and this is
something that healthy cells do as well
with other small rnas
and with all of this introduction I hope
you know where I'm going with this
basically if ancares are only expressed
in cancer cells and some of them do in
fact find their way into the bloodstream
doesn't it mean that we should be able
to detect them in blood samples from
cancer patients the answer turns out is
yes but with an
asterisk so the ancarat that we detect
in blood samples from patients actually
form a partial barcode and it's only a
partial barcode because only a subset of
anaras are actually secreted from cancer
cells into the blood and even a smaller
subset can be reliably detected in a
small volume of blood however thanks to
the magic of machine learning and AI we
can actually use this partial
information to reconstruct the original
barcode that resides in the tumor and we
can match that de construction against
our catalog of UNC carnate barcodes
across cancer to not only AC Cross
Cancer is not to not only detect the
presence of the disease but also
identify its type or subtype and
actually as we grow uh fundamentally
increase the number of these uh encar
catalogs that we have built we can go
deeper and deeper into the biology of
the disease as
well now with help from our clinical
collaborators at UCSF we have come a
step closer to actually bringing this
platform to the clinic and a preliminary
study uh across 200 breast cancer
patients we have actually shown that we
can use ENC carnas to detect residual
disease in uh patients after they have
received treatment and knowing which
patients have remaining disease tells
clinicians who needs additional
treatment or monitoring uh after the
surgery and this way patients receive
more treatment only when it's
needed I truly believe that the next
decade is the decade of cancer screening
and as you can imagine blood detection
of cancers is a major Frontier in that
war and I hope to have convinced you
today that leveraging powerful AI built
on top of molecular barcodes of
anaras we can Envision a future that
precise and sensitive but more
importantly very accessible blood
detection of cancers is not just a hope
but it's actually a
reality thank you